[Música]
o tema que eu vim falar é sobre escola
do avesso que eles dizem que é um
sistema inteligente de ensino nesses
últimos 25 anos eu tenho conversado nem
conversei com mais de seis mil crianças
e adolescentes
alguém já conversou com o estado do
menino aqui então eu vou compartilhar
com vocês aqui o que nós conversamos
nesse tempo todo
nesses anos mas antes eu queria
compartilhar com você e com vocês e com
o mundo né uma experiência fantástica
que eu vivi
junto com a minha família a júlia minha
esposa está ali eu fui para a áfrica em
1991 quando fala em áfrica a angola cada
um pensa uma coisa né e ao contrário do
que muitas pessoas acham que é um país
muito pobre é um país que só tem miséria
ao contrário é um país muito lindo de
pessoas muito empreendedoras muito
artistas muito acolhedoras e eu
trabalhei lá na usina hidrelétrica de
capanda que era uma usina hidrelétrica
que estava sendo construída 500
quilômetros de da capital luanda e
angola ela foi teve um processo de
independência que aconteceu em 1975
libertação de angola e onde três
partidos políticos se juntaram para
expulsar os portugueses e eles
conseguiram conseguir a independência e
mesmo assim a guerra continua
existem histórias para quem quer
continuar ou aprofundar nesse assunto
existem muitos livros é muito
interessante estudar a história de
angola e eu estava em casa era meia
noite quando eu fui justamente no ano de
1991 quando a onu solicitou exigiu que
parasse com aquela guerra para ter uma
eleição justa entre as aqueles que
estavam pleiteando o poder e nós
chegamos então nesse período onde estava
ocorrendo esse processo de
eleição e no dia que ia sair o resultado
estava em casa com a minha família com a
júlia
adriele a mariana linda estava na
barriga da mamãe é e o braço direito de
um dos líderes falou olha não divulga o
resultado vocês vão conhecer angola vai
conhecer uma guerra que nunca viu que
começou ali a guerra eu saí correndo com
a minha família a júlia andriele ficamos
dentro de um bueiro de meia noite até 4
horas da manhã e ver a onu nos resgatou
e trouxe o brasil e aí começa essa fase
na usina hidrelétrica aquela de que a
panda e muito interessante para quem se
interessa por história é aprofundar na
história de evolução de angola que cada
vez mais é um país muito promissor é um
país muito rico e que vale a pena e
quando eu cheguei ao brasil fui
convidado por três irmãs dominicanas pra
quê pra pensar e desenvolver uma
proposta para trabalhar nessas e
adolescentes
esse projeto tinha o nome de projeto dos
meninos e meninas e ele não existia
então não sabia muito um dia chegar e
com atividades diárias lá tentando
entender essas seis mil crianças nesses
25 anos que a gente instalar muitas
histórias tristes né menino que estava
com a gente lá na sexta feira fazendo o
papa tem foto dele no sábado ele mente
para a mãe que foi para a casa do colega
e foi para nova ponte morreu afogado e
voltou então tem muitas histórias
tristes né
e ao longo desses anos o menino que não
gosta de estudar menino se envolvendo
com drogas
meninas envolvimento com prostituição e
[Música]
se deparando todos os dias e conversando
com essas crianças a gente pensou
a gente precisava muito uma coisa na
educação se o estudo é uma coisa tão
antes na vida das crianças e eles não
estão gostando de estudar e quando eles
falam sistema inteligente de ensino
ele teve uma posição também da gente
refletir em cima de problemas né
a unesco que são dados da unesco que 617
milhões de crianças não estão aprendendo
e será porque eles não estão aprendendo
a normose alguém já ouviu falar
é uma doença psíquica que tudo que
fazemos né e que acaba se tornando
normal né mas que de alguma forma vem a
nos prejudicar é e uma menina essa
semana mesmo ela na hora de matricular
a gente tem uma conversa de uma hora e
quarenta e fala marca muito tempo falou
não não é muito tempo uma hora e
quarenta matriculando a menina pra
ambientá-lo ela ambientá-lo no sistema
escola do avesso
então eu pedi para escrever uma frase do
jacaré sob o morro e quebrou a perna e e
uma letra horrorosa e não eu perguntei
para ela você essa letra bonita ela
falou à bbc tem certeza disso presta
atenção na sua lista é igual de médico
eu falei você acha normal essa letra
se você fosse contratar uma pessoa essa
força seu cartão de mostrar essa letra
você contrataria ela não então percebi
que a partir de uma fala já compreendeu
que aquilo não é normal uma letra
daquele jeito ea gente faz aquela
reflexão as escolas deveriam abolir o
caderno normal deveria ser só caderno de
caligrafia porque a menina não está
aprendendo mesmo eles vão chegar burri
no final do ano mas com a letra bonita
já é alguma coisa né e daí surgiu essa
idéia nessa escola do avesso é
justamente uma escola ao contrário e é
um local muito bonito lá no bairro
leira onde tem restaurante tem diversos
espaços em sala de aula e o sonho era
fazer uma piscina e nós conseguimos uma
quadra poli esportiva e eu precisava de
100 caminhões de terra para fazer o
aterro e eu com todos os meus contatos
né curso e não consegui ficar um mês e
meio dois meses tentando conseguir as
terra pra aterrá eo menino chegou para
mim e falou max fala a vida inteira que
vai ter uma piscina que pizza no carro
arranca até por lá dentro da quadra
aí foi rápido e chamou seu ruy que mora
ali perto
pagamos quatro reais para ele foi lá
acabou tirou toda a terra e colocou é da
quadra
depois vem um parceiro depois de um ano
e estava aquele matagal naquele buraco
que o buraco é esse a gente só em fazer
uma piscina e eles deram dinheiro pra
fazer uma piscina hoje tem duas piscinas
lindas lá no local
graças a quem ama não era criança e no
processo de matrícula
a gente tem uma fala com eles o seguinte
quando fala que é inteligente ensino
porque trabalha o educacional aquilo que
eu sei o emocional aqui que eu sou
a gente fala muito que é importante que
o sucesso de uma pessoa às vezes não
está no que ele sabe mas o que ele é
então quando fala inteligente é por isso
que trabalha o emocional científico eo o
educacional e científico eo emocional
o desenvolvimento humano a gente
trabalha o científico em alguns
professores que não gosta a gente
explica a meninada se quando o professor
vai dar uma aula para a turma inteira
sobre o que é o elefante
ele precisa lá na áfrica isso na
matrícula eu faço com os meninos
individualmente ele precisa lá na áfrica
ele precisa de algum zoológico onde ele
vai
eles não conseguem responder raramente
um fala no google
no livro mas eles não falam
eu falo é no livro sabe que ele faz ele
não sabe se o elefante vai na casa dele
e o elefante tem rabo do elefante tromba
do elefante de orelha grande
o elefante com capim elefante mora na
áfrica o elefante tem medo de rato
porque o rato entrou na turma dele a
gente chega no outro dia na sala de aula
fala menino nós temos um modo muito
importante hoje sobre o elefante o
elefante tem tromba do elefante tem rabo
do elefante de orelha é grande
o elefante económica e ele tem medo de
rato e sabiam ele tem medo de rato
porque ele tem me ajudado e tem medo do
rato entrar dentro da turma dele
os meninos falar e mas esse professor
sabe sabe nada ele foi lá naquele lugar
chamado livro
então essa proposta de desenvolvimento e
aceleração educacional mostra isso que é
possível sim aprender sem estar na
dependência de um professor
a gente fala logo em seguida você sabe
que tem um nerd a e um menino
inteligente fala não um nerd diferença
do nerd pra vocês uma questão de atitude
já sabe tudo o que ele precisa saber
está nos livros está a fazer cupcakes
não sei se você quiser fazer agora você
dá conta do na internet
eu gostaria de seu livro o seu livro que
passa sexta sábado sábado e domingo
trancado na escuridão da sua mochila não
então você pode sim tirar 10 não para
competir com os outros
então eles ea gente está dando certo
gente a gente vê que a meninada quando
entra na escola talvez eles falam agora
estudar nunca mais eu aprendi a gostar
de aprender
então essa é a parte uma das formas de a
gente trabalhar
a aceleração do desenvolvimento
educacional eu particularmente acho que
a casa residência para viver a
convivência familiar não é estudar e
mais no finalzinho eu vou fazer uma
reflexão sobre isso e sistema
inteligente de ensino a partir do
campeonao fazer que eles gostam de
aprender que eles entendam que o
professor é importante sim mas
não pra dar aula na escola talvez não dê
ao da aula pessoas não dá aula eles são
os professores
então existem algumas ações alguns
projetos um chamado jornadas que promove
essa aceleração educacional e outro lado
marcos você falou desenvolvimento humano
inteligência emocional a gente vê muita
gente entrando nas drogas
se tiver muita gente fazendo coisa
errada tanto eles não sabe que é errado
isso e porque que entra em gente fala
para lenita assim ea mãe de olho é
porque sempre entrevista a mãe tá
olhando se você fosse lido uma barata
você seria o que pensa não é barata se
fosse filho de um jacaré e se o jacaré
seja da condenada um rio
as baratas e sacode andar na parede se
você sofre de um contínuo passado vocês
não dá conta de voar certos e são filhos
quem de deus é de deus
então vocês são um é começar de novo é
uma barata do jacaré
você é um filho de uma águia você é um
que ele respondia você é filho de deus
né só então aí os meninos de deus eh eh
eh
se você pegar a baratinha ipca em 500
pedaços em cada pedacinho de ver você
tem porque 500 barato então nós somos
pitadinha de deus olha quem tá olhando
para os ele a olhou deus
a mãe dele falei é quando você entra no
banheiro sozinho
deus não fala vai no banheiro sozinho eu
vou esperar aqui de fora ele entra com
você
já vi uns em deus cortar morto em cima
de uma mesa ali não tem vida então deus
é vida então a sua essência é divina
deus não é bom não tente andar nas
paredes não vai cair
não tente voar que não é sua essência
não vai dar certo então a sua essência é
divina existe deus e encardido que eles
têm poder
só que o encardido escolheu fazer o
estado ruim né então a sua essência
divina exercitar a cada vez mais em
direção a essa sua essência é dolorido
não é fácil eu vou te provar que você é
meio isso que eu falei uma divindade
você deus é onisciente onipresente
onipotente tudo ele sabe tudo ele pode
ele não é isso aí eles podem tudo quanto
é lugar
você agora se quiser ir para frança como
se faz
enquanto não dá foi ele o computador vai
sair quem fez isso foi o homem não deus
que está no homem e com e provei que né
você pode estar em tudo quanto é lugar
você pode falar de deus pode tudo e só
de você
ah não não posso falar pode você pode
chegar agora na sua casa pegar enfiar a
mão dentro da calça comprida do seu pai
roubar dinheiro pode não pode
você não pode sair agora sair correndo
enfiar a cabeça dessa parede posso tudo
você pode aproveitar sua essência é
divina
agora deus sabe tudo sabe e você não se
você tiver um menino da sua idade
se tivesse conversar todos os colegas
que está conversando e fazendo tudo que
você queria que ele trocasse escolhem
tirasse alguns hospitais com todos todos
todos falam alguns cai na piscina a
folga e através do rua o carro e pega
por isso a mãe tem que cuidar quando
você chega sete aninhos já começa a
funcionar o primeiro poder ser quer
saber de tudo
somente ensinou que não pode comer
barata uns fala assim eu já falei dúvida
é mãe falou nunca disse nem milena
somente ensinou que é barato não só uma
gestão que não pode comer terra não como
ser
como se aprendeu a fazer noção fará
noção isso é deus é o poder que você tem
então desenvolver a inteligência
emocional parte da gente reconhecer a
nossa essência de que a nossa essência
divina a gente quem conseguiu mais
aproximar disso foi nosso irmão jesus
tem uma senhora e uma das perguntas é o
seguinte você quando você desenhar
careca ou cabeludo todos fala cabeludo
um barco sem barba com barba nas noites
quentes nas nuvens então deus não é esse
não
deus está em todos os lugares em todas
as pessoas é eu queria então a escola da
vez essa proposta ela tem o objetivo de
promover o auto de batismo as pessoas
falam que é que se é igual a metodologia
escola do avesso da escola
a sala de aula invertida e gosta da
escola do avesso à escola do avesso é
acredita que os meninos não deve estudar
em casa a não ser que eles queiram ea
escola a sala de aula divertida tem uma
proposta dos ministros lugar em casa e
trazer as dúvidas pra escola né então eu
queria agradecer a oportunidade de estar
aqui com vocês e dizer que é uma alegria
muito grande e hoje a gente tem o sonho
de expandir essa proposta educacional
para outros lugares saiu já em dois
portais lá em angola
lá na áfrica um abraço pra ver o mundo e
nenhum abraço dos nossos amigos lá de
angola ea mensagem que a gente deixa
essa né agradecimento e dizer pra vocês
lá entre no instagram rouba escola do
avesso
[Música]